[Musique]
bonjour à tous je vous souhaite tout
d'abord une très belle année 2024 je
suis ravie de vous retrouver aujourd'hui
dans ce nouveau numéro du skycho le
magazine qui raconte toutes les
aventures économiques du territoire de
Saint-Quentin en iine alors pour cette
première édition de l'année nous allons
parler innovation nous irons à la
rencontre de Benoît Dentan dirigeant et
fondateur de xD mootion cette société
spécialisée dans la captation vidé mise
sur deux choses la créativité et
l'innovation technologique nous y
reviendrons un petit peu plus en détail
dans ce numéro mais tout de suite voici
le sommaire un nouveau moyen de
transport à l'île de loisirs de saant an
Yveline dès la fin du printemps 2024 10
capsules autonomes sur rail seront
expérimentés auprès du grand public
objectif créer un circuit de 2 km entre
un site d'hébergement et la future fan
zone située sur le grand parking dans ce
numéro nous irons à la rencontre de
Benoît Dentan dirigeant et fondateur
d'XD motion mondialement connu pour ses
innovations technologiques l'entreprise
est spécialisée dans la prise de vue
vidéo lors de cet entretien vous
découvrirez comment xdmotion continue
d'innover grâce aux nouvelles
technologies en collaboration avec la
société Nexio le Laboratoire national de
métrologie et d'essais inauguré le 19
décembre 2023 sur son site attrape une
nouvelle cage de radiofréquence dans ce
numéro je vous emmène en immersion à la
découverte de ce laboratoire de dernière
[Musique]
génération
1 2 3 ça va l'Urban lope est sur la
bonne voie ce mardi 19 décembre le
ministre des Transports Clément baunne
était à l'île de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline présentation du
véhicule et pause du premier rail un
moment symbolique pour annoncer
l'expérimentation de ce nouveau moyen de
transport pour les Jeux Olympiques 2024
un circuit de 2 km desservant le grand
parking lieu de la future Fan Zone et un
site d'hébergement au niveau du Relais
Des canardières c'est une très belle
innovation pour les transports et pour
les mobilités C innovation qui est
électrique innovation française qui
associe l'Université des entrepreneurs
des élus et Saint-Quentin a été
justement au rendez-vous dès le départ
maintenant nous sommes prêts et c'est
important d'être à l'heure des Jeux
Olympiques parce que c'est le moment où
on va pouvoir avoir assez de voyageurs
pour expérimenter ce qui est aujourd'hui
une mobilité totalement innovante c'est
encore une fois décarboné donc qui
participe à ces grands objectifs qu'on
se fixe de sobriété alimenté par un
courant de très basse tension dans les
rails les 10 futures capsules seront
autonomes et piloté par des algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle elles
pourront chacune deux passagers un
trajet écologique à 50 kmh à moins d'un
centime d'euros le kilomètre curban loop
c'est un système de transport qui est
dédié aux zones de moyenne densité c'est
pas le centrreville de Paris pas le
centrville de Marseille mais des villes
comme saintctin niveline où on souhaite
être plus rapide que la voiture on ne
fait pas la tentequ il y a toujours des
véhicules qui viennent se recharger
comme des télécabines sur les dans les
stations on arrive on rentre on appuie
sur la station ou sur laquelle on
souhaite aller les portes se ferment et
après le véhicule va directement à sa
destination sans s'arrêter débuté en
septembre 2023 3 les travaux se
poursuivront jusqu'à la mi-janvier avec
la pose des derniers rails les navettes
hyperloop seront testées à vide dès
février avec une ouverture au publicque
à la fin du printemps cette
expérimentation de 17 mois d'un coût de
5 million d'euros est financé à hauteur
de 800000 € par l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin en
[Musique]
yelin depuis sa création 2011 xD motion
parcourt la planète pour retransmettre
les plus grands événements du monde
exposition universelle de Dubaï concert
de Colpin en passant par le Tournoi des
six nations l'entreprise cinquantinoise
est reconnue mondialement pour ses
innovations en matière de retransmission
vidéo sa marque de fabrique des prises
de vue aériennes et en mouvement à
partir d'avion de drone de traveling sur
câble et rail motorisé cette technologie
elle est notamment développée par un
homme Benoît d'Anton bonjour bonjour
vous êtes dirigeant et fondateur de
xdmotion alors premièrement bah c'est
quoi xD motion alors xD motion
effectivement c'est une société très
spécialisée dans les prise de vue en
mouvement donc on installe des caméras
qui vont être stabilisé sur hélicoptère
sur cble cam sur système de voiture
traving r traving drone et cetera donc
notre innovation principalement est
d'avoir des tout types de support qui
vont permettre de faire des
retransmission sportive culturelle ou
autres qui vont donner une image
absolument extraordinaire de ces type de
prise de viUe ouais et du coup vous
pouvez nous parler un petit peu de de
ces captations vidéo avec quoi vous
travaillez exactement bon je vais
prendre quelques exemples puisque là on
est sur une année olympique he donc déjà
bonne année et et cette année va être
une année très innovante donc là c'est
ce dernier ces derniers tournages sur
Noël 2023 et début d'année on a fait le
concert de Jean-Michel jar à Versailles
et là on a fait une très très belle
captation en installant pour la première
fois bah ce robot vous voyez ici qui
était installé dans la galerie des glace
qui a filmé Jean-Michel Jard en direct
donc pour des milliers de
téléspectateurs avec tout un monde
virtuel et puis un système de caméra sur
câble aussi virtuel qui est assez
spectaculaire par rapport à ses
utilisation et le drone dans le cadre
des Jeux Olympiques ce même robot je
vous le donne en scoop va être utilisé
pour la cérémonie d'ouverture des Jeux
Olympiques et ce robot va être installé
sur des bateau qui vont suivre la
cérémonie donc il va être monté sur le
sur des structures sur le haut des
bateaux et ce qui permettra de descendre
le la caméra sous les ponts et remonter
de l'autre côté afin de pas de de
permettre d'être au même niveau que les
sportifs qui vont tous être présents sur
les bateaux et que nous allons filmer
voilà deux exemples qui vont être
réalisés avec cette technologie
incroyable et donc du coup bah pour les
Jos là ça y est vous êtes à la maison
vous êtes un habitué de cette cérémonie
comment vous êtes organisé pour pour
cette cérémonie en tout cas pour alors
on a travaillé depuis plus d'un an sur
la préparation puisque xemotion et le
fournisseur officiel des drones de prise
de vue pour la cérémonie et les cabble
cam que l'on va fournir on est sur
sa-quenttin sur quatre sites euh donc le
BMX le le VTT euh on va tourner sur le
vélodrome et le golf avec beaucoup de
systèmes innovants de de cabble Cam
notamment sur le sur le VTT qui était
complexe parce que voilà on est dans des
jeux écologiques mais aussi on est dans
dans des forêts qui sont un patrimoine
dans la forêt de d'élancour et donc on a
dû respecter d'énormes règles euh afin
de ne toucher à rien de ne pas bétonner
site pour pouvoir justement mettre ces
caméras très spectaculaires et donc
l'innovation elle part pas uniquement
sur la prise de vue elle part sur tout
le concept général qui entoure nos
systèmes de de prevu comment on va
s'accrocher quel type de caméra on va
utiliser mais aussi comment on va
transmettre et cetera donc il y a
beaucoup de de de de de de
différentes possibilités pour cela sur
lequel on doit étudier en profondeur h
et récemment vous avez utiliser la 5G
par exemple au Vélodrome pour le
cyclisme vousz c'est une technologie que
vous allez utiliser pour les Goos avec
Nokia et orange et le consortium que
Saint-Quentin a mis en place on a été
financé par la Ville et par donc le ce
ce consortium qui nous a permis en fait
de de de sur les derniers championnats
du monde qui ont eu lieu au Vélodrome
d'utiliser la 5G à titre
expérimental nous avons fait réaliser
des images en 360° et de l'arité
augmentée transmise en 5G c'est pour
nous un facteur d'avenir très important
euh on travaille vraiment d'arrachepied
avec Orange et no a sur cette capacité
de pouvoir transmettre ses images en
live comme si c'était des moyens
traditionnels euh on attend que l'ARSEP
qui est donc l'autorité qui nous
permettra de de de d'obtenir ces
fréquences très spécifiques nous nous
nous autorise à les utiliser ce qui sera
le cas euh sur des bandes privées lors
de la cérémonie et différents sites dont
Saint-Quentin et Marseille lors des des
Jeux Olympiques donc on attend beaucoup
de cette technologie là qui nous
permettra de transmettre nous nous
sommes prêts de notre côté il faut que
maintenant celui qui transporte le
signal nous nous nous nous laisse nous
nous connecter et après ça fonctionnera
tout seul h et pour le pour le futur euh
vous avez peut-être d'autres projets
peut-être d'autres innovations avec
lesquelles vous aimeriez travailler
alors oui euh on a aujourd'hui beaucoup
de choses notamment avec Jean-Michel jar
sur de nouveaux projets puisque c'est
qu' c'est un c'est un artiste qui a
véritablement fait un cœur d'innovation
depuis des années des années et qui
défend ai auss les entreprises
françaises comme la nôtre donc ça c'est
très agréable aussi de travailler avec
lui sur ce sujet-là et donc on
l'innovation finalement c'est de réunir
des briques technologiques de
différentes sociétés françaises qui vont
venir apporter chacun leur savoir faire
sur un projet donc vous avez un artiste
comme Jean-Michel jar sur lequel il va
avoir des casques virtuels links
français un système audio d'une autre
société française xD mootion Pour les
caméras aériennes ou robotisé et cetera
et cetera en lumière euh en système de
de tracking en système de de montage
live et cetera donc l'innovation pour
moi euh c'est le regroupement de toutes
ces entreprises qui finalement font un
pool et là vous imaginez bien que chaque
ingénieur va venir apporter sa brique à
l'édifice et donc créer quelque chose de
super innovant donc c'est ça l'avenir il
est là c'est plus de travailler dans son
coin dans son entreprise à essayer de
pas être concurrence et cetera au
contraire c'est de s'ouvrir maintenant
grâce à tout ce qui se passe
mondialement et à la communication qui
de plus en plus active facilement c'est
de réunir toutes ces entreprises et si
possible dans le Bassin parisien proche
de de des Yvelines pour pouvoir
justement créer ces technologies du
futur h et alors les prochains projets
vous allez travailler bon sur les JO et
après vous voulez tout savoir bah oui
alors euh là on est sur les Championnats
du Monde de VTT en discussion euh ça va
être quelque chose d'important le
tournois à destination qui reprend après
la belle coupe du monde de rugby que
nous avons réalisé au Stade de France
qui était quelque chose d'assez
spectaculaire et innovant on a réalisé
les prises de vue hélicoptère sur ce
domaine-là euh et ensuite je dirais que
ça va être principalement des concerts
euh là en innovation on a aussi la Mode
là on va réaliser le défilet Louis
Vuitton euh la fin de la semaine
prochaine qui va être très très innovant
parce qu'on va utiliser trois cble cam à
l'intérieur donc de la salle al je peux
pas trop en parler parce qu'on est sous
accord de confidentialité mais en tout
cas ça va être quelque chose de très
spectaculaire à voir en terme de de de
de de de prise de vue artistique et pour
la mode
euh dans mes rêves les plus fous je
pense que je je j'ai très envie de de de
de créer une relation entre les
ingénieurs et les techniciens pour créer
ces techn là et on y travaille donc il
faudra vous êtes obligé de revenir dans
quelques semaines oui parce que je peux
pas encore tout vous dévoiler tout de
suite mais ça va venir bon plein de
bonnes choses alors pour la suite et ben
merci beaucoup bah avec plaisir cl merci
et nous on continue cette édition en
partant à la découverte du nouveau
laboratoire d'essessais de
radiofréquence
ne de
[Musique]
trappe bonjour je suis Bernard P je suis
le directeur adjoint des essais de la
certification du
[Musique]
hen c'est un établissement public un
acteur public qui depuis plus de 120 ans
accompagne les acteurs privés et publics
dans leur démarche d'innovation et
accompagne les industriels lors du
développement de leurs produits
vis-à-vis du marque H et la mise sur le
marché dans le cadre de nos
investisement et de nos développements
nous avons eu le plaisir d'inaugurer le
19 décembre 2023 un tout nouvel
équipement le le nouveau laboratoire de
[Musique]
radiofréquence
alors ce projet il a deux raisons tout
d'abord il y a de plus en plus de
modules de communication connectés qui
sont intégrés dans les produits
industriels il y a une forte croissance
lorsqu'on regarde les les les données
quantitatives on peut estimer que d'ici
2025 on aura un peu plus de 21 milliards
d'objets connectés dans le monde et donc
il y a une nécessité derrière cela de
pouvoir tester et évaluer ses produits à
la fois en terme de performance de
robustesse et de sécurité la deuxième
raison aussi de cette investissement
c'est qu'on a un contexte réglementaire
évolutif et assez contraignant tous ces
produits connectés sont soumis à une
directive la directive raid qui
s'applique avant la mise sur le marché
de ces produits connectés pour obtenir
le marquage CE et permettre aux
industriels de pouvoir vendre ses
produits sur le marché européen
[Musique]
nous avons souhaité collaborer avec NiO
qui est une société d'ingénierie dans le
domaine de
l'électromagnétisme et qui a des
activités orthogonales et
complémentaires à celle du LNE ils
interviennent beaucoup plus en phase
amont de la conception des produits
alors que nous LNE nous allons
intervenir et accompagner les
industriels sur la mise sur le marché
avec des tests de performance et et de
d'évaluation de robustesse et avec
également une ambition commune pour
Nexio et LNE de développer et de mettre
en œuvre cette plateforme de laboratoire
en
[Musique]
radiofréquence je m'appelle Arnaud
Fayette je suis responsable technique
radio Olne depuis maintenant 2 ans
donc ici on est dans une chambre
semianécoïque à 3 m donc semianécoïque
pourquoi parce qu'il y a un plan de
masse réfléchissant au sol donc cette
chambre c'est une cage de phadé donc
l'extérieur est entièrement métallisé de
façon à ce que les ondes ne rentrent pas
à l'intérieur de l'enceinte tout autour
on a mis des tuiles de férite on en a
20000 ils ont tous été fixés à la main
un à un sur ces tuiles de férite on est
venu aajouter des absorbants donc les
tuiles comme les absorbants on pour rôle
de faire en sorte que les ondes ne se
réfléchissent pas à l'intérieur de la
salle de façon à ce qu'on puisse mesurer
ce qui provient du produit donc l'idée
ici c'est de disposer le produit sous
test donc là on peut avoir des produits
qui font à peu près 2 m de haut par 2 m
de large jusqu'à à peu près une tonne et
on les met en place sur ce plateau
tournant et en face on a un M d'antenne
qui peut aller de 1 m à 4 m et sur
lequel on va venir connecter les
différentes antennes en fonction des
bandes de fréquences qu'on va venir
[Musique]
regarder pour nous
ne ce laboratoire il vient compléter
l'offre globale dont on dispose on fait
déjà au LNE la CEM dans deux autres
casage on fait également la sécurité
électrique pour les produits industriels
et médicaux et donc pour répondre à
l'ensemble des exigences essentielles il
nous manquait ce laboratoire radio pour
venir mesurer les performances radio des
équipements donc là l'idée ici c'est on
dispose d'une antenne cornet donc cette
antenne cornet elle nous permet de
mesurer tout ce qui se passe dans la
bande de fréquence de 1 GHz à 18
GHz juste derrière cette antenne là on
retrouve un boîtier alors ce boîtier il
est unique en France ensuite les signaux
radio sont envoyés via un câble qui va à
l'extérieur de la cage se connecter sur
un récepteur de mesure qui va de 1 Hz à
40 GHz et c'est ce récepteur de mesure
qui nous permet justement de faire la
trace RF du
produit une fois que le Produit est
placé dans la chambre de mesure on
utilise un logiciel de mesure qui a été
réalisé par la société Nexio et donc
l'objectif c'est que le produit les
émissions du produit qu'on voit en bleu
ici reste sous les courbes rouges qui
sont les limites définies par les
normes
les avantages pour les entreprises qui
vont pouvoir bénéficier de cette
plateforme unique au niveau européen
c'est tout d'abord un délai beaucoup
plus court dans la conception de leur
produit ils vont également gagn en délai
sur le time to market la mise sur le
marché et bien évidemment sur le coût du
projet puisqu'ils vont
bénéficier sur un site unique et un
guichet unique de l'ensemble des tion
nécessaire pour pouvoir évaluer et
tester leurs produits avant la mise sur
le marché on va PIR tester les produits
connectés qui vont utiliser les réseaux
5g et à terme les réseaux 6G et donc
pour les consommateurs ça sera un
bénéfice de pouvoir bénéficier de
produits SR tester et vérifier on
continue à investir sur les les
technologies de demain
c'est-à-dire l'intelligence artificielle
et la cybersécurité et donc notre
prochain investissement qui est en cours
c'est le futur laboratoire d'évaluation
des systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
le la immersion que nous allons
inaugurer en février
[Musique]
2024 on termine avec l'agenda ce mois-ci
ne manqueit pas le webinaire club 2024
le 15 janvier à 15h au ski cube venez
découvrir le site de célébration déployé
durant les Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024
rencontre proposera également aux
entreprises des opportunités business
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur
[Musique]
tv78